la primera vacuna anti kobe de américa
latina podría llegar pronto cuba
comenzará entre el 3 y el 8 de marzo la
fase 3 de ensayos clínicos en las
soluciones de soberana 2 y abdalá la
última fase antes de su validación unas
pruebas que serán simultáneas al inicio
de la producción industrial de las
vacunas expertos cubanos se muestran
esperanzados y también han demostrado en
la inclusión de una potente respuesta
inmunológica las vacunas cubanas están
desarrolladas con la técnica de la
proteína recombinante que consiste en
estimular la respuesta del sistema
inmune científicos destacaron que no
habrá límite en el número de dosis por
lo que se podrá inmunizar cada seis
meses cuba está trabajando en otras dos
soluciones
la soberana uno que ha concluido su
primera fase de estudios y mont visas
que se aplica mediante spray nasal hace
unos días la isla caribeña anunció que
espera empezar la vacunación masiva en
su población antes de que acabe el
primer trimestre cuando sólo si todo
sale bien este año debemos una
el país ha controlado el avance del cob
y 19 durante prácticamente toda la
pandemia sin embargo tras la reapertura
de aeropuertos en octubre se produjeron
rebrotes que obligaron a detener la des
escalada actualmente cuenta con cerca de
50.000 casos y más de 300 fallecidos
cuba dedica una cuarta parte de su
presupuesto a la salud con una gran
apuesta por la biotecnología como
demuestra el desarrollo de vacunas en el
pasado para la meningitis ve el cáncer
de pulmón y los tumores sólidos entre
otras soluciones